[Music]
what's up Troy Gins it's your boy Troy
just right off the bat want to keep it
real with you guys going a little naked
without my ring light but you know what
we still out here as you guys know I
don't usually like to talk about my
to be honest I've been going through
some low-key personal stuff lately and I
just feel obligated to let you guys know
that long story short
gay my mama coma
she's down for the count for
we don't really know how long
unfortunately that's just kind of how
Comas go but fear not fam even though I
never really vibed with my mom's camp
and spent my Summers doing dope
with my friends I happen to be a
financial Guru and world-renowned
business Mentor yeah I do that kind of
stuff your boy has the bde that's right
the business development expertise to
hold down the food oh my God there's a
person I'm so sorry I'm so sorry I was
in here fixing the blinds and then you
came in and I panicked and stayed oh I'm
Glenn I'm the technical director
how you doing man over the next three
weeks I'm gonna give you an inside look
at how I can take a business from lamb
to LIT let's build the most pressing
matters are in the main stage right now
the Cyclorama is buckling it needs to be
re-anchored we're going to need to
prioritize the remaining equipment for
the musicals which means the straight
plays are going to have to be acoustic
which is actually how they do it on
Broadway
because you are real quick it seems like
you got a pretty good handle on this so
I'm just going to take understanding a
word you're saying
off my list and let you take it from
here brother okay quick question though
what's a straight play
well there there aren't musicals and
then there are straight plays
so then what would be a gay play
I guess I'm a musical
oh cool
[Music]
foreign
when I was young
and we said these songs are true these
days
[Music]
I'm letting you in oh God
oh I've been here 10 minutes and it's
unbearable oh my God
he's like wandering about he's no idea
where he is what he's doing he can't see
no he only talks to his camera it's oh
my God the least creative person I've
ever met and I've yet to speak to the
man
clay ball
half the staff has been cut they're not
even coming back we need a coup we need
well there's not even enough of us to
have a coup now
she wouldn't even
we really have to hold this place down
artistically
I can't believe the John's not here I
can't
[Applause]
all I was doing was blowing the roof off
of honestly sincere and Bye Bye Birdie
then I look over to my house seats and
there's Joan with convulsing what was
frightening
character
all right let's take a knee with the
talking fam
listen up
Keep It Down Bam
Squad again
maybe uh zip it everybody could we just
get you guys
[Applause]
oh
what up adorondo
[Music]
um you guys know Joan right
[Applause]
yeah
um so she's not here
um you know which we're all very sad
about but don't worry I'm her son Troy
[Music]
um don't worry guys just want to
reassure you this will be a normal
summer you can check out my website oh
yeah very good thanks so much hi guys
so a few reminders I just need to know
all of your updated sizes also sad news
I will not be doing piercings anymore in
the hut
yeah because there's an arc amongst us
um Cassie has narked it's totally fine
uh yeah okay I love you guys love you
foreign
ER head of drama Rebecca Diane head of
Music Theory we are now going to
announce as we do every summer
this session's Productions
seven eight
[Applause]
about a girl named Lisa she wanted to
perform but she didn't have her visa
sorry about your Visa Lisa five six
seven eight playing baseball with the
Devil in a baseball diamond Damn Yankees
in the outdoor stage
who goes there
is it a ghost
is it a witch The Crucible Junior in the
lobby in the land of Andrew Lloyd where
the felines sing and dance
whisker-faced in unitards you can join
their feral Prince cats immersive well I
Guess That's all folks I gotta start
walking home I'm taking a cab
an original piece and it's fully brand
new and it's fresh from our hearts
written just for you but you've gotta be
good yeah you've gotta be great you've
got to be the creme de La Creme of the
place
[Music]
foreign
this summer it's a story about a woman
and her glory
the founding of a space that has become
our favorite place
a woman who all in this room deeply love
and she's looking down not quite from
above
Joan can
Joan will Joan here
Jones still
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]